The reality television series "American Pickers"
has been a constant presence on History's
programming schedule for over a decade, and
remains a fan-favorite show to this day.
"Finally I catch a break."
Since the series' premiere in January 2010,
the stars of "American Pickers" have traveled
near and far, searching the United States
for valuable pieces of history housed in shacks,
sheds, shops, storage containers, and more.
Considering that there's plenty of territory
the stars haven't covered in the show's 22
seasons, it stands to reason that "American
Pickers" could last another decade or more
on the air.
Of course, that depends on whether or not
the network and the series' trio of hosts
— Mike Wolfe, Frank Fritz, and Danielle
Colby — choose to stick around.
However, based on the most recent batch of
episodes, that may not be the case.
Wolfe and Colby were back in action for more
antiquing adventures, but when "American Pickers"
premiered its 22nd season in January 2021,
Fritz was nowhere to be found.
He was also absent for the show's midseason
return on June 7th, which got fans talking.
Discussion about Fritz's Crohn's disease diagnosis
— which explains his recent weight loss
— prevailed in some circles, while others
pointed to Jersey Jon taking his place as
a sign that Fritz's "American Pickers" tenure
could be coming to an end.
"No. No. No"
Here's what we know about Frank Fritz's "American
Pickers" status.
While there isn't a ton of concrete information
out there about why Fritz has been missing
from recent episodes, outlets like Celeb Hook
are claiming that there are a few factors
preventing his immediate return.
First and foremost, COVID-19 is still a problem,
and since Fritz is someone with a serious,
pre-existing medical condition, risking catching
the virus is surely something he would want
to avoid.
Neither Fritz nor anyone part of the "American
Pickers" team have confirmed this as a reason
for Fritz's absence, but a press release issued
ahead of the show's arrival in Missouri in
May 2021 reveals that the cast and crew are
taking things seriously regarding COVID-19
safety.
The press release reads, in part,
"We understand that with the proliferation
of COVID-19, we are all facing very uncertain
times.
We at American Pickers are taking the pandemic
very seriously and will be following all guidelines
and protocols for safe filming as outlined
by the state and CDC."
The U.S. Sun has also claimed that Fritz was
quarantining in Iowa, where he recently sold
his and his ex-fiancé's home.
It's also worth mentioning that Mike Wolfe
has acknowledged Fritz's disappearance, with
Reality Titbit reporting Wolfe's announcement
that Fritz underwent back surgery for an undisclosed
reason.
Over on the "American Pickers" Facebook page,
one fan confirmed in a comment under a photo
post in March 2021,
"[Frank's absence] has been addressed in a
past episode.
[...] Frank had back surgery, he's recovering."
The commenter added that in a later episode,
Frank's name was mentioned twice, which should
be proof that he, in their words, "obviously
hasn't been cut out of the show."
Though it's unclear what Fritz had surgery
for, some types of operations on the back
or spine can require a lengthy recovery period.
According to Neurosurgeons of New Jersey,
patients spend at least one day, often more,
in the hospital immediately after surgery,
then endure between six to eight weeks and
several months of recovery.
Patients will likely begin physical therapy
one to three months following surgery, and
that the frequency, intensity, and overall
duration of therapy sessions differs depending
on the type of surgery the patient had and
their surgeon's recommendations.
Having and recovering from back surgery, managing
Crohn's disease, selling a house, and avoiding
catching and spreading COVID-19 would overwhelm
just about anyone — and Frank Fritz is likely
no exception.
"I need a break."
With COVID-19 vaccination numbers soaring,
according to Bloomberg news, and mask mandates
being slowly rolled back as well, hopefully
Fritz will feel more comfortable hitting the
road with his longtime co-host Mike Wolfe
— and digging through America's biggest
treasure troves in the near future.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.